- The fake McDreamy's back, AKA me.
I'm gonna be watching my second
episode of Grey's Anatomy
alongside you guys.
Let's get it started.
Bee, whoop!
(lively music)
(static hisses)
- [Man] Turn up the TV.
- [Reporter] A massive
train wreck occurred
just outside of Seattle minutes ago.
- 911? We just worked a 30 hour shift.
- I don't have any clean underwear.
- [Reporter] The Vancouver-bound
train was carrying...
- That's crazy, they
worked a 30-hour shift
and they can get paged to go back?
- Hello. I seem to be a little bit drunk.
I was off duty.
- So was I.
Anybody else half in the bottle?
- [Together] No.
- I don't get why she would
come in to her shift if she's drunk.
That's not helpful to anybody,
and if she starts performing
any kind of medical procedures
while under the influence,
that's not good for patients,
that's not good for her,
it's just a subpar solution,
so I don't really understand
what she's even doing there.
She should be making a
little love with McDreamy.
- Was that a nod?
- Yes.
- Do we know what it meant?
- No.
- Am I invisible?
- How much romance?
I feel like this isn't
a medical show anymore,
it's just a romance show.
(dramatic music)
Whoa.
What is that?
That.
- [Meredith] Okay, fine.
Maybe it's the second worst.
That was crazy.
- So are you gonna pull this
pole out of us anytime soon?
- Touch uncomfortable.
(laughing)
- I'm sorry, we can't do that
until we get a better look
at what's going on internally.
But I assure you, we will
work as quickly as possible.
- They're taking this very not-seriously
and a lot of humor with a pole
jammed into two peoples' bodies.
Whoa, that's all I can
really say right now.
Something that I think
needs to be done immediately
is to give them some sort of back support
so that they don't get fatigued and tired
and start slouching, 'cause
if they are to slouch
when they get tired, and they
obviously will get tired,
they can do more internal damage
with that pole going through them.
- You are drunk.
Go get yourself a banana bag IV,
put it in your arm and then find me.
Do not speak to any more patients,
do not practice any medicine.
- IV drips do not stop hangovers.
This is why so many people are
opening these IV drip spas,
especially in Vegas I
see that happen a lot,
and they promise you that it's gonna
block or cure your hangover.
An IV will hydrate you the same
that you can hydrate yourself
by drinking some water
or drinking some fluids
with electrolytes in them.
Now that being said, it's
gonna be a little bit quicker,
but then again you're
also increasing risks
'cause you're opening a hole
in your skin to get that IV in.
Something to mention about hangovers
is that it's not all about dehydration.
A hangover is like a catchall term
for all sorts of symptoms.
Nausea, vomiting, fatigue,
dizziness, a dry mouth.
Yes, hydration may help
some of these things,
but it's a complicated process
that has a lot of things going on in it.
Just giving yourself hydration
is not the sole answer.
- No, no, no, we're fine honey, yeah.
Some redneck tried to outrun the train.
Honey, the train slammed into his ass
and then it rolled.
- [Alex] That hurt?
- [Patient] Mm-mm.
- [Yvonne] Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
That dude is toast.
- He was doing sutures, it
looked like, above her eyebrow.
No doctor would perform sutures like that.
Keeping your hands elevated like that
from a lowered position and doing sutures
you're gonna get fatigued so quickly,
and your hands are gonna start shaking,
and you won't be able to do it right.
You always need to be
above the given situation.
- [Yvonne] Where you going?
- I'm taking your friend for an X-Ray.
- Oh. (laughs)
No offense little boy, but, uh,
you look like my oldest son
and he's nothing but trouble.
- Yvonne, shut up.
- What, I said no
offense, I'm just saying.
Are you sure you're a doctor?
(playful ringtone rings)
- I get that all the time.
- [Izzy] What are you doing?
- Trying to insert my banana bag.
Which sounds vaguely dirty, but it isn't.
- A banana bag is just an
IV bag with normal saline,
which is fluids with electrolytes in them.
There's also some vitamins in there.
Generally, this is given to people
who are chronic alcoholics,
'cause they're usually nutrient depleted.
Giving a banana bag to someone
who's healthy and had a few drinks
pretty much useless.
Just have some water
and give it some time.
- [Cristina] His legs.
- What about them?
- They're both left.
(playful music)
- Find the man's leg, Yang.
Find it now.
- [Cristina] Yes, sir.
- They got the wrong leg?
- Is it going straight through her spine?
And why did she say it only then?
- [Derek] These people are still alive?
- They're still making smalltalk.
- Pole's tamponading the
wound as far as we can see.
- When she says that the wound
is being tamponaded by the pole,
it means that it's exerting pressure
and actually preventing
them from bleeding.
That's why if you ever get
stabbed with something,
it's never ideal to just
pull it out automatically
until you have medical care.
That object, whatever it is,
is putting pressure to stop the bleeding.
- What if we move one of the patients
off the pole to get the saw in there?
Then we can hold the pole
steady in the other one.
Move it very slowly and
repair the damage as we go.
- Who? Which would you move?
- With her aortic injuries,
her chances of survival
are extremely slim no matter what we do.
- I don't really buy the realism of this.
The aorta is a pulsatile vessel,
meaning that every time the
heart beats, the aorta moves.
So if you have a metal pole
that's going through the aorta
and has cut it open,
there is no way that pole is
putting that much pressure
that it's preventing her from bleeding out
unless it's crushing it or compressing it
in such a weird way.
- So basically whoever you
move doesn't stand a chance.
- Why can't they just cut
the pole from in between them
and then separate them
and go...
- So how do you choose?
How do you decide who gets to live?
- You're a cute doctor.
Cute doctors get to call
me by my first name.
- Bonnie.
- Mm.
- Okay, Bonnie.
- Oh, McDreamy.
Can you feel me rubbing your foot?
- Could you try to wiggle
your toes, Mr. Maynard?
- Are they moving?
- Yes they are.
- Huh, good. (laughs)
That's good, right?
- Yes it is, yes it is.
- What about me, are mine moving?
- Yes they are.
- (sighs) Yay, me.
- That's probably one of the situations
it's okay to lie to a patient.
- Is there any chance that we can
get out of here sometime this year?
- Well, the lab's backed
up and so is radiology
and I can't discharge your
friend until I'm certain
she doesn't have any internal injuries.
(playful ringtone rings)
Nowadays, we decide if
someone has internal bleeding
with an ultrasound called a FAST scan.
- If I don't find this leg,
the chief is gonna cut
me from this program
and I cannot go back home, Burke.
It is too sunny on Los Angeles.
It's sunny everyday.
- I don't understand what she expects.
Does she think that the
chief is gonna be like,
you couldn't find this leg in the rubble
so that's it, you're cut from the program?
I don't understand what her thinking is.
Is this supposed to be
like a comedic aspect?
Is she being sarcastic?
- In order to operate on Mr. Maynard,
we have to separate you two.
In order to do that, we have to move you
backwards off the pole.
(sad music)
- Can't just pull the
pole out of both of us?
- Well if we did that,
you would both start
bleeding very quickly.
Too quickly.
Right now, the pole is
plugging the wounds.
Once removed, the organs will shift.
And there is a great deal of damage.
- So, if you move me, I'll die?
- You're being ridiculous.
You're gonna be fine, do you hear me?
- I hear you.
But we still have to sign the forms.
Unless you want our son
to end up with my mom.
(playful music)
(laughing)
- How long have you two been together?
- Since third grade
- Aww.
- We're not lovers,
we're best friends.
- Oh.
- We just wanted our
kids to have two parents.
So we got a sperm donor.
- The same donor.
So your babies are brother and sister?
- Oh, how cool is that?
- (laughs) That's, wow.
- Oh my god. (laughs)
God, who writes this stuff?
(playful ringtone rings)
(papers shuffle)
- Yvonne, answer your phone.
Yvonne, Yvonne.
(Yvonne thuds)
(tools clatter)
Yvonne!
- Uh oh, Yvonne looks like
she passed out.
- Code Blue!
- We need some help over here!
- Okay, first thing you
do during a Code Blue:
chest compressions, chest
compressions, chest compressions,
chest compressions.
But also, before you call a Code Blue,
you gotta check for a pulse.
'Cause Code Blue means
someone's heart has stopped.
And just because someone's unconscious,
it doesn't mean they're a Code Blue.
So my man needed to go right
up there to the carotid,
or to the femoral artery,
or to the radial artery,
this is usually the best place,
and feel if there's a pulse.
If there's no pulse, yelling for help
while doing chest compressions.
- She's lost too much blood,
she's been bleeding for hours.
- There's no blood, she's not bleeding.
- She was bleeding internally.
- What's interesting
about the abdominal cavity
is that the back portion,
the posterior portion,
which we call the retroperitoneal area,
it can actually store a lot of blood.
So you can be having a very slow
leak of blood into that area,
and not really know that
you're bleeding out.
The one thing that makes this less likely
is that she was talking,
she was moving around.
Generally, if you're losing blood
you start having symptoms
like you feel fatigued,
your eyes are closing,
you feel like you're
gonna faint or pass out,
your blood pressure starts dropping,
you could even be having
some abdominal pain,
'cause blood is a natural
irritant to the abdominal cavity
so you start feeling pain,
and then once we do our exam
we'll note that you have an acute abdomen.
We would do an ultrasound or a CAT scan,
find the bleeding, and then take you in
for what we call an
explorative laparotomy,
where we literally open up your stomach,
by stomach I mean the
skin of your abdomen,
look around, check the entire intestines,
find where you're bleeding, fix that area,
put everything back in, sew you back up,
and get you up and moving again.
But in this case, she's lost so much blood
that she went into cardiac arrest,
meaning her heart stopped.
Now he's doing the advanced
cardiac life support procedure
where he's giving epinephrine,
he's doing chest compressions,
he's helping her breathe with the bag,
and hopefully trying to get her pulse back
and get her heart beating again.
- No, no, no, Yvonne!
- I'm sorry.
Time of death, 2:51.
(dramatic music)
- [Nurse] Watch her head.
- [Nurse] Clean towel.
(saw whirs)
- [George] Meredith.
- [Bailey] Doctor Grey.
- What about her?
We cannot just abandon
her, we have an obligation.
- I'll take care of this.
Meredith, come on, come on.
There was too much damage.
There was never anything we could do.
We have to let her go.
Time of death, 3:49.
- One of the most difficult
parts about medicine is triage.
Knowing who you can help in a given moment
and knowing where to use resources
when they're very limited.
Some of those decisions
are heart-wrenching,
they're incredibly difficult to make.
At times, it feels like you're playing God
and it's putting you in
the most unfair situations.
But you have to do your best,
given what limited resources you have,
and what limited information you have,
to make the best possible
and fairest decision.
I applaud all first responders
in these types of
mass-casualty situations.
Growing up in New York
City, thinking about 9/11,
what that must have been like
for people who were working
in the local New York City hospitals,
it scares me, it blows my
mind all at the same time.
I've trained in Level 1 trauma centers
during my medical school time,
and just having a few people
come in with gunshot wounds
or knife wounds, or bicycle accidents,
those are incredibly stressful situations.
You never know what to expect.
You always have to be
thinking quickly on your feet.
So then to imagine what it must be like
when hundreds of people or
even thousands of people
are coming in, wow.
So, huge thank you to all the people
that have ever been involved
or may ever be involved
in those types of
situations in the future.
We really respect you and
thank you for your service.
- Did she suffer?
- No.
Her injuries...
- Again, these conversations
don't happen in the open.
This is not right.
- Better get cleaned up.
Rounds in five minutes.
♪ Today has been okay ♪
- I don't get it.
They work 30 hours (laughs)
then they come in for an emergency,
look like they worked
for another 12 hours,
they've been working for 42,
now they're going to morning rounds?
Do they ever get time off?
Oh man, you guys recommended a doozy here.
It presented an interesting situation,
unfortunate for the patient that died.
Kind of shows you that
doctors are sometimes
put into really tight spots
where they have to use
limited information, limited resources,
and sometimes let one life
go in order to save another.
That's a very, very, very
unfair and tight situation
that we find ourselves in.
That's what we asked for when
we decided to go into medicine
and that's why it's a beautiful field
and we get so much admiration
put upon us as doctors,
because we have to make those decisions.
I like Grey's Anatomy, it's a fun show.
There's a lot of drama in it.
So if you have some more episodes,
maybe ones that are more medical
and less like, oh my god, McDreamy,
does he love me, does he love me not?
Like I know that's important,
but I would love to comment
on some more medical aspects of the show.
Drop it down below in the comments.
Hit that Subscribe button
and the notification bell
so that you know when all
my videos are coming up.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(static hisses)
That's why if you ever get
stabbed with something,
it's not ideal to just pull it out
until you have medical
care around you, because...
(horn blares)
What even was that?